how immature do you have to be as a 70  plus year old man so first of all  there's  the the the desire to keep power  and maybe trump was imagining  if pence were president and i was the vp  i would be using this opportunity  to try to somehow seize the power of the  presidency when the president is being  sedated for a colonoscopy so maybe  trump's idea of i don't want to give it  up to pence was rooted in if i were  pence i'd be trying to seize power we  don't know but that certainly tracks  with donald trump  but then the other part of this is  you know the idea that you're gonna be  laughed at because you got a colonoscopy  in your 70s rather than hey you know  what this is a great opportunity to talk  about the importance of routine  screenings and colonoscopy being a part  of that but no that's not the way that  trump functions so it all tracks here